The latest reports put the death toll for the coronavirus at more than 1,000, mostly in China,...
...making the situation larger than the SARS outbreak nearly 20 years ago.
In Syria, nearly 700,000 people have been displaced since early December...
...due to increasing conflict across the country, described by the United Nations...
...as "the biggest displacement crisis in the world."
In Sudan, the Sudanese government and rebel groups from Darfur...
...jointly agreed that all those wanted by the International Criminal Court...
...should appear before the tribunal.
Among those wanted is former ousted president Omar al-Bashir.
In Lebanon, security forces used tear gas and a water cannon against protesters...
...who gathered outside Parliament to protest an upcoming vote on the country's financial crisis.
Finally from Britain, the government has approved the High Speed 2 rail project,...
...Prime Minister Boris Johnson announced.
The plan was originally approved a decade ago,...
...but has now been adjusted to finish by 2030, with a projected cost reaching 137 billion dollars.